THE SPECIAL GRAND JURY IN FULTON
COUNTY, GEORGIA HAS COMPLETED
ITS INVESTIGATION NOW INTO
TRUMP'S EFFORTS AND ALL OF THOSE
AROUND TRUMP TO OVER TURN THE
2020 ELECTION RESULTS IN THAT
STATE.
WE DO NOT YET KNOW THE RESULTS
OF THIS SPECIAL GRAND JURY'S
FINDINGS BUT WITH DO KNOW THERE
IS A HEARING ON THE BOOKS.
THE JUDGE HAS SCHEDULED IT FOR
LATER THIS MONTH TO DECIDE
WHETHER THE GRAND JURY'S REPORT
SHOULD BE MADE PUBLIC.
THE FINAL DECISION ON WHETHER TO
BRING ANY CHARGES AGAINST TRUMP
OR ANYONE FOR THAT MATTER WILL
BE MADE BY THE FULTON COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY FANNIE WILLIS.
AND SARAH, WHAT ARE YOU HEARING
ABOUT THIS?
WHAT IS THIS JUDGE SAYING?
>> WELL WE KNEW THEY WERE
WORKING ON THIS FINAL REPORT AND
NOW THE JUDGE IS SAYING THEIR
WORK IS COMPLETED, THAT THE
SPECIAL GRAND JURY HAS BEEN
RESOLVED.
THEY WERE SEATED IN MAY OF 2022.
THEY HAD THE POWER TO SUBPOENA
WITNESSES, AND THEY THE POWER TO
GATHER EVIDENCE, THEY HAVE BEEN
DOING THIS AND THEY HAVE NOW
COMPLETED THIS FINAL REPORT.
BUT AGAIN, PROSECUTORS WILL GET
TO SEE, BUT IT IS AN OPEN
QUESTION WHETHER THE PUBLIC WILL
GET TO SEE IT.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT LATER ON THIS
MONTH.
AND IN THAT HEARING.
BUT THIS IS AN INVESTIGATION
THAT STARTED WITH THE NOW
INFAMOUS PHONE CALL THAT DONALD
TRUMP MADE TO GEORGIA SECRETARY
OF STATE BRAD RAFFENSPERGER
ASKING RAFFENSPERGER TO HELP HIM
FIND THE VOTES.
TAKE A LISTEN TO A PORTION OF
THE CALL.
>> ALL I WANT TO DO IS THIS.
I JUST WANT TO FIND 11,780
VOTES.
WHICH IS ONE MORE THAN WE HAVE.
>> NOW DISTRICT ATTORNEY FANNIE
WILLIS SAID AFTER THAT CALL SHE
FELT SHE HAD TO OPEN THIS
INVESTIGATION.
IT IS A EXPANDED THOUGH WELL
BEYOND THE CALL TO INCLUDE THE
FAKE ELECTOR SCHEME, TO INCLUDE
MAKING PRESENTATIONS THAT WERE
RIDDLED WITH CONSPIRACY THEORIES
ABOUT THE ELECTION BEFORE STATE
LAWMAKERS, TO INCLUDE EFFORTS BY
UNAUTHORIZED PEOPLE TO ACCESS
VOTING MACHINES IN AT LEAST ONE
COUNTY.
SO THERE IS A LOT THAT THIS
GRAND JURY HAS BEEN POURING
OVER.
EVERYONE IS VERY EAGER TO SEE
WHAT IS IN THE FINAL REPORT AND
TO SEE IF THEY RECOMMENDED ANY
INDICTMENTS.
IF SO, THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
COULD THEN PURSUE THOSE CHARGES.
>> STICK WITH US.
AND YOU HAVE GREAT PERSPECTIVE
ON THE LONG INVESTIGATION.
AND JOINING US RIGHT NOW IS
MICHAEL MOORE, A FORMER U.S.
ATTORNEY FOR THE MIDDLE DISTRICT
OF GEORGIA.
IT IS GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK COULD BE IN
THIS FINAL -- IN THIS GRAND JURY
FINAL REPORT?
OF COURSE IT HAS NOT BEEN MADE
PUBLIC BUT COULD CHARGING
RECOMMENDATIONS BE INCLUDED?
>> YEAH, WELL I'M GLAD TO BE
WITH YOU.
I THINK IT IS LIKELY THAT THERE
ARE CHARGING RECOMMENDATIONS IN
THE REPORT.
REMEMBER THAT THE REPORT REALLY
IS AN INSTRUMENT NOT JUST FOR
THE GRAND JURY BUT FOR THE D.A.
AND THE PROSECUTORS HAVE HAD
THEIR HANDS ALL OVER IT.
THE GRAND JURY IS NOT SITTING IN
THERE WITH NOTEPADS LISTED OUT
EVERYTHING THEY WANT TO HAVE AND
SOMEBODY IS TYPING THIS UP AT
NIGHT.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS DONE
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
PROSECUTOR'S OFFICE, GETTING
THEM THE WISHING OF THE GRAND
JURY AND ANY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS THEY HAVE ABOUT THE
EVIDENCE THAT WAS PRESENTED TO
THEM.
SO PROSECUTOR KNOWS WHAT IS IN
THE REPORT.
NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, I ALSO
WILL KIND OF PUT THE CAUTIOUS
INSTRUCTION OUT THERE, THIS IS
THE BEGINNING OF THE PROCESS.
THE EVIDENCE PRESENTED TO THE
GRAND JURY, AND THE WITNESS
TESTIMONY PRESENTED TO THE
SPECIAL GRAND JURY HAS NOT BEEN
CHALLENGED, IT HAS NOT BEEN
TESTED BY CROSS-EXAMINATION OR
OTHER DEFENSE COUNSEL EFFORTS.
SO THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF WHAT
WE WOULD SEE IN A NORMAL CASE.
THAT IS THAT IS THE PROSECUTOR
HAS TO SEE IF SHE'S GOING TO
SEEK A REGULAR INDICTMENT.
I DON'T THINK WE'LL SEE A
SPECIAL REPORT WITH NO
RECOMMENDATIONS IN IT.
THE QUESTION WILL BE WHO HAVE TE
RECOMMENDED THAT SHE CHARGE.
AND ON WHAT CHARGES.
>> THAT IS ACTUALLY RIGHT.
AND ALSO, MICHAEL, SARAH WAS
LAYING OUT THERE IS A COURT DATE
SET FOR THE PARTIES INVOLVED TO
ARGUE OVER WHETHER THE REPORT
SHOULD BE MADE PUBLIC.
DO YOU, MICHAEL, THINK IT WILL?
WHAT DO THOSE ARGUMENTS LOOK
LIKE?
>> WELL, I THINK IT IS A
DANGEROUS PRECEDENT FOR THE
JUDGE TO MAKE IT PUBLIC IN THIS
CASE.
IN GEORGIA WE HAVE AN OPEN
RECORD STATUTE.
AND ONE OF THE REASONS THAT WE
DON'T SEE INVESTIGATIVE
MATERIALS AND INVESTIGATE
REPORTS IN ANY PENDING CRIMINAL
CASE IS BECAUSE THE STATUTE SAID
THAT IS A REASON NOT TO DISCLOSE
INFORMATION UNTIL THE CASE IS
CONCLUDED.
SO THIS WOULD REALLY CHANGE
PRECEDENT AND SORT OF, I GUESS,
BE AN ARGUMENT THAT YOU WOULD
SEE MEDIA ORGANIZATIONS AND
DEFENSE COUNSEL MAKING FROM NOW
ON.
IF IT IS THE NORMAL THING NOW TO
RELEASE INVESTIGATIVE MATERIALS
BEFORE WE GET TO A GRAND JURY,
WE'RE GOING ASK FOR THAT IN
EVERY CASE.
SO THERE IS A STRONG ARGUMENT
THAT THIS OUGHT TO REMAIN IN THE
PRESS AND THE PROSECUTOR THAT
SHE COULD CONSIDER IT AND THAT
SHE COULD THEN MAKE HER DECISION
ABOUT MOVING FORWARD WITH THE
REGULAR GRAND JURY.
IT'S A DOUBLE-EDGED SWORD, IF IT
COMES OUT PUBLIC, IT WILL
JUSTIFY HER EFFORT AND EXPENSE
THIS FAR.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME IT PUTS
PRESSURE ON HER TO FOLLOW THE
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
SPECIAL PURPOSE GRAND JURY THAT
SHE ASKED TO BE CONVENED IN THE
CASE.
WHILE SHE MAY MAKE SOME
STATEMENTS ABOUT MAKING THE
REPORT PUBLIC, SECRETLY SHE'S
HOPING TO MAKE IT PRIVATE AND
DECIDE WHAT SHE COULD PRESENT TO
THE REGULAR GRAND JURY.
>> THAT IS VERY INTERESTING.
AND SARAH, YOU COULD REMIND
PEOPLE THE LONG LIST OF THE BIG
NAMES WHO WERE CALLED AND SOME
OF THEM FORCED AFTER LEGAL
BATTLES TO TRY TO AVOID IT TO
APPEAR BEFORE THIS SPECIAL GRAND
JURY.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF BIG
NAMES GO INTO THIS GRAND JURY.
WE DON'T KNOW EVERYONE WHO HAS
GONE IN THERE AND THEY'VE HEARD
FROM MANY WITNESSES.
BUT WE KNOW THAT RUDY GIULIANI
WAS ONE OF THE PEOPLE WHO SHOWED
UP BEFORE THE GRAND JURY.
WE NOR THAT BORIS EPSTEIN WHO IS
ANOTHER ATTORNEY TO FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS THERE.
SOUTH CAROLINA SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM FOUGHT THIS TOOTH AND
NAIL.
HE APPEARED BEFORE THE GRAND
JURY.
BRAD RAFFENSPERGER AND BRIAN
KEMP AND MARK MEADOW WAS ORDERED
TO APPEAR AFTER HE HAD BEEN
FIGHTING A SUBPOENA FOR HIS
APPEARANCE AS WELL.
SO THEY GOT INFORMATION FROM A
NUMBER OF THESE PEOPLE AND ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE HEARD FROM
WITNESSES IS THAT THE GRAND JURY
WAS VERY INVOLVED IN SORT OF
ASKING THESE WITNESSES FOLLOW-UP
QUESTIONS.
THEY HAD VERY CLEARLY BEEN READ
IN ON THE MATERIALS.
SO AS MIKE WAS SAYING, THEY WORK
WITH THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY TO
PULL TOGETHER THIS FINAL REPORT.
BUT WITNESSES HAVE DESCRIBED A
VERY ACTIVE GRAND JURY
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND MICHAEL, OF COURSE, AS YOU
MENTIONED, THE BIG QUESTION WILL
BE HOW AND WHEN ANYONE LEARNED
IF THIS YEARS' LONG
INVESTIGATION LEADS TO AN
INDICTMENT.
JUST ON THAT QUESTION OF TIMING,
WHEN DO YOU THINK WE WOULD KNOW?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IS PROBABLY
BEEN WORKING ON THE INDICTMENTS
AS WE SPEAK.
SINCE THEY KNOW WHAT IS IN THE
REPORT.
SO IT IS SIMPLE TO CALL TOGETHER
A GRAND JURY, IN A REGULAR
CRIMINAL TERM AND MAKE A FAIRLY
CONCISE PRESENTATION TO A GRAND
JURY.
TO MAKE A CASE BEFORE REGULAR
CRIMINAL GRAND JURY, SHE WOULD
HAVE TO LAY OUT EVERY WITNESS
AND EVERY PIECE OF EVIDENCE.
SHE COULD DO THAT IN A SUMMARY
PRESENTATION.
SO SHE COULD BRING IN A COUPLE
OF A WITNESSES AND SOME
RECORDING STATEMENTS IF SHE
WANTS TO, SOME DOCUMENTS IF SHE
HAS THEM AND LAY OUT THE
FINDINGS THAT WERE MADE BY THE
SPECIAL PURPOSE GRAND JURY.
AND ANY OTHER INVESTIGATIVE FIND
THAT SHE'S MADE.
SO SHE COULD GET AN INDICTMENT
WITHIN A COUPLE OF DAYS, I
THINK.
AND HER TEAM WILL TAKE A MONTH
OR TWO TO DEVELOP THE CASE A
LITTLE FURTHER.
ONCE THE DECISION IS MADE ABOUT
THE REPORT AND THEN IF
INDICTMENTS ARE GOING TO COME
OUT, I THINK YOU'LL SEE THEM
CERTAINLY BY SPRING.
>> IT WAS ALSO, SARAH, JUST TO
WRAP IT UP, IT WAS SAID BY A LOT
OF SMART LEGAL MINDS
THROUGHOUT -- OVER THE LAST YEAR
THAT THIS REALLY WAS THE
INVESTIGATION THAT THE PEOPLE
AROUND DONALD TRUMP WERE MOST
NERVOUS ABOUT, MOST CONCERNED
ABOUT AND A LOT OF -- AND A LOT
OF LEGAL ANALYSTS SAYING THAT
THEY SHOULD BE MOST CONCERNED
ABOUT IT IN TERMS OF DONALD
TRUMP'S EXPOSURE IF HE -- ANY
KIND OF LEGAL EXPOSURE THAT HE
DOES HAVE.
I'M CURIOUS AS TO HOW PEOPLE
FEEL ABOUT THIS NO AS IT MOVES
INTO THE NEXT PHASE.
>> I THINK IT IS SHIFTED A LOT
BECAUSE THE CONCERN WAS BEFORE
WE KNEW THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
HAS SUCH A ROBUST INVESTIGATION
INTO EFFORTS TO OVERTURN THE
2020 ELECTION AND AROUND JANUARY
6.
WE KNOW MORE ABOUT THE SCOPE OF
THE INVESTIGATION AND THAT IS
BEFORE THE MAR-A-LAGO
INVESTIGATION BECAME A PROBLEM,
SORT OF HOARDING THESE SENSITIVE
DOCUMENTS AT MAR-A-LAGO.
I DO THINK ONE THING IS VERY
CLEAR, DONALD TRUMP HAS ALWAYS
BEEN AT THE CENTER OF THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S CASE IN
GEORGIA.
THE FEDERAL CASE MAY REACH TO
DONALD TRUMP, AND MERRICK
GARLAND MAY HAVE A DECISION TO
MAKE BUT I THINK IT WAS ALWAYS
VERY CLEAR AT LEAST IN GEORGIA,
THIS WAS AN INVESTIGATION INTO
THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
>> GREAT REPORTING AS ALWAYS,
SARAH.
MICHAEL, THANK YOU FOR JUMPING
ON.
I APPRECIATE IT.